Mean-shift is a method that's easiest
introduced, when we do segmentation.
The idea is, in Mean-shift, is to
find the modes of a distribution, or
of a probability density.
So, you remember, the modes are sort of,
the peaked areas, and
here's the basic underlying assumption.
The assumption is, I've got a bunch of
samples, that have been drawn from some
probability distribution function,
and you want to find the modes.
So, there's this beautiful couple of
beautiful examples out there on the Web,
feel free to steal whichever
one you want, I stole this one.
So, here we have a set of particles, and
they're just drawn from some density.
And probably,
if I were to ask you where's the mode?
You'd probably, say,
that it's somewhere around here.
'Kay, and the goal is for
the system to find that on it's own.
So, here we have, and again,
we have our sample, so
let's put down a region, okay?
It's called a Region of interest.
Now, we're not going to talk about,
the size of that region just yet, or
its shape.
We'll talk about that,
a little bit later.
It's going to be a Gaussian, but, for
now, it's just going to be a circle.
So, we have this region, and
we calculate, okay, of all of
the points in that circle, where is
the mean, that's, or the center of mass?
And we say, oh,
it's not right in the middle, and
that difference between them,
that's called the Mean Shift vector, so
this is called the Mean Shift algorithm.
Amazing huh?
And so, what do you do with
the Mean Shift vector?
Well, you shift the mean,
and there it go.
[NOISE] Perfect.
Okay?
What do we do?
We do it again.
Okay?
Here's where we are.
Here's the, the weighted mean of the,
the new samples.
There's our Mean Shift vector.
What do we do?
We shift it again.
[NOISE] And we do it one more time.
There it is, oh,
we're getting close now.
Small Mean Shift vector, shift, and
then finally, guess what,
we are in the right spot.